we have a new moral standard here in the
West
and this is being represented in our
symbols the USA has just redesigned its
soccer Logo USA has a soccer team
apparently news to me I can't say I
follow it all that closely but the USA
has a soccer team and the USA now
they're about to play some soccer match
in the Middle East
and they've redesigned their logo the
logo is no longer red white and blue
the logo is the rainbow
it's the gay the gay pride flag
and you can see this on their larger
logo it says one nation
USA gay pride flag doesn't say one
nation under God they've clearly gotten
rid of that that reference one nation
but not with the SIM the traditional
symbol of our nation which is the red
white and blue it's no it's the rainbow
flag
because the rainbow flag is in many ways
the new American flag
I promise you the Liberals in this
country identify much more closely with
the rainbow flag than they do with the
American flag with the Stars and Stripes
the rainbow flag is the symbol not of
the traditional American Nation but of
the American Empire
that's why we fly Pride Flags in
Afghanistan that's why we fly Pride
flags at the Vatican that's why we do it
as a statement of American Empire also
because the pride flag
connotes Universal values
the American flag the traditional
American flag is a flag of a nation that
says this is what our nation is about
and we're going to be a shiny city on a
hill
we're going to be a beacon of freedom to
the world but this is for us
the pride flag is for everybody the
pride flag is just to conquer everybody
and to say that that these new values
that we have enshrined uh in this case
of sexual
uh eccentricity are they're for
everybody and actually you you have to
accept them the reason they're doing
this in the Middle East is because the
Middle East has a different much more
traditional view of these sexual matters
and so the the United States through the
soccer team are saying no you you will
adopt our views we're going to go in
there if you don't allow for the sexual
Revolution to flourish we're going to go
in there we're going to impose it on you
and we've done that many many times
because that's the flag of our Empire
right now head on over to kamikodo.com
Knowles using techniques that have been
honed and perfected by generations of
bladesmiths kamikoto knives are crafted
only of high quality Japanese steel each
kamikoto knife goes through a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish with more than 100
years of experience between them
kamikoto's expert bladesmiths shape raw
Japanese steel into hearty blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine single bevel Edge
this sharp edge is why kamikoto knives
can cut through Meat and Fish like
butter and why they are used by Michelin
rated chefs around the world each knife
is individually inspected and comes with
a a lifetime guarantee plus kamikoto
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box for safe storage this
stunning presentation makes kamikoto a
great gift during this Christmas season
kamikoto is now running a Black Friday
sale and offering my viewers an
additional fifty dollars off any
purchase with discount code Knolls go to
kamikoto.com Knowles and get your knives
set and help support this channel
if Republicans have control of the house
what's good is that the Speaker of the
House presumably Kevin McCarthy or some
Republican leader maybe McCarthy will
face a challenge after this week
performance in the midterms at least the
Speaker of the House can refuse to take
up certain bills he will have certain
procedural power to quash some democrat
uh priorities and one of those
priorities
that any Republican speaker should
should fight one of those priorities
that any Republicans in the Senate
should fight
is one of the most radical bills I have
ever seen
go through our Congress it is a bill to
radically redefine marriage
it is a bill to enshrine into law the
obergefell decision which was a
constitutionally Preposterous decision
to invent a new definition of marriage
and shoehorn it into the Constitution
somewhere
uh Chuck Schumer is now saying according
to CNN's Congressional correspondent
that he has got 60 votes to Ram this
bill through
don't forget the Senate still has a
filibuster so Schumer doesn't just need
a bare majority Schumer needs 60 votes
which means he needs Republicans to vote
to radically redefine marriage and to
punish people for opposing this insane
absolutely incoherent definition of
marriage that flies in the face of all
of civilized tradition every major
religion and human reason in the natural
law
I'll put this into no uncertain terms
because I I know that conservatives even
and and certainly Republicans are kind
of mixed on the issue of how to how to
define marriage but when it comes to
this bill any Republican who votes for
the radical redefinition of marriage
bill
should be expelled from the party
any Republican and I'm I'm just laying
this out there now so that the
Republicans understand that there
actually is still some opposition to
this that there are actually still some
people who are willing to defend the
actual definition of marriage that every
single human being on Earth including
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
believed up until about five minutes ago
because it is just a fact of reality and
no amount of semantic gamesmanship or
romantic poetry from the Supreme Court
can change it any Republican who who
supports this nonsense should be
expelled from the party and you these
Republicans are probably going to be
thinking well look if five of us
or six of us or ten of us support this
bill they're not going to be able to
primary all of us there's not going to
be the political will there's not going
to be enough money for it fair enough so
what I think we should make clear right
now is
the Republicans who support this bill
and there will be a few squishes I think
that conservatives who still understand
what conservatism means and what
marriage means we should pick one of
them we should pick the weakest one of
them the one who we can most
least expensively primary and kick out
of office and we should concert our
effort to remove that Republican okay so
I don't know who that Republican is
going to be is it going to be Mitt
Romney is it going to be some other
squish whoever it is we should pick that
person and make an example of that
person and we should turn all of our
political Firepower on that person to
remove him from office to send a message
that we we will not stand idly by well
the conservatives quote unquote squish
on everything that matters including the
fundamental political institution which
is the family which is marriage just so
that we can I don't know what maybe get
some tax cuts sometimes
for some gazillionaires in Silicon
Valley who hate our guts anyway
I don't think so we're not going to do
that all right you know on this marriage
bill you'll sometimes hear people
say some Republicans or some
conservatives who are or even liberals
who are trying to catch us they'll say
wait I thought you were the party of
small government
I thought I thought Republicans were the
party of small government now you want
to define marriage okay first of all
Republicans are not the party of small
government we are not in theory the
party of small government and we are not
in practice the party of small
government the Republican party was
founded on big government the Republican
party was founded to abolish slavery
okay and the first Republican president
was Abraham Lincoln he was a big
government conservative he suspended
habeas corpus okay the guy was not small
government now you might say well that's
bad okay I'm just telling you the
history of the Republican party we have
had eight Republican presidents since
Calvin Coolidge not one of them has
shrunk the government
not one of them
not Eisenhower not Nixon not Jerry Ford
not the bushes not Reagan not Trump and
not not one of them has shrunk the
government
you might say well that's bad okay I'm
just telling you the history of the
Republican party we are not the party of
small government we are not the party of
reducing the size and scope of
government sometimes we pretend that we
are on television but that's not
actually what the Republican Party does
and I don't even support small
government I don't think there can be a
small government in a country of 330
million people that governs a global
Empire
I like government within its just limits
but that's a different thing
what what role does the government have
in marriage
well I don't know marriage is the
fundamental political institution so if
the state does not have some interest in
the fundamental political institution
then the state doesn't have an interest
in anything and then we're all
anarchists which we're not I'm not at
least I'm no Anarchist okay I think we
need
good rules we're going to have rules
we're going to have a society we're
going to have laws and so they should be
good rules and not rule rules that
punish good stuff and promote bad stuff
but quite the opposite today we will be
discovering all sorts of new genders on
tick tock
I usually interview people on on
Tuesdays but you know listen today today
is all about Trump's announcement we're
going to be talking later on for that so
I figured we needed to mix it up a
little bit get some open our minds on
these questions of gender the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]